I want it...
...and I would love to have the first one.
I'm so sorry Mr. Seinfeld but you're number two on the list.
Who's number one?
That guy.
Okay.
So, you're number one.
Yeah.
How would you like to be number 20?
I'll throw in the Soup Nazi.
Soup for you.
I own all the characters.
Last living munchkin.
I thought he passed away.
I found another one.
Dancing holographic monkey?
I have one.
I'll make small talk with the omelet guy for you.
Do you ever take an egg home with you?
Is your head that shape underneath the hat?
Do you ever feel bad about coming out of the toilet and then coming right back to work here?
Nobody knows it.
You do.
Yams?
Anybody like dirty limericks?
Nobody wants any yams, sweetheart.
Beat it, I'm trying to get a roll going.
I'll recap last week's episode of Jersey Gangland for you with sock puppets!
Manicotti is dead.
I run the Boardwalk now.
He's still here?
Yes.
Sorry, that's a bad idea.
How about a new boat?
Final offer.
For the record, I don't think I like you quite as much as I did at the beginning.
I'm listening.
Access to my personal network of Manhattan zip-line!
Wow! Impressive!
You got the first Acura NSX.
How about a jetpack flying squirrel suit?
New York to LA, twenty minutes!
Sorry, Jerry!
The Acura NSX.
It's coming.
Leno.
All right, can we talk about something else?